[Applauso]
regate di ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono parigino ci siamo su fa fai
perdi non so non vedere ma io non lo so
l'inglese di pips che credo si chiami
così praticamente è un gioco c'è il
simbolo di un pannolino quindi merita la
vita consiste nel presente c'è questa
coppia è così che si fanno i bambini
però insegno io e sfruttato un bambino
dal nulla non sapevo fosse così io posso
prendere il ban
vabbè gioco dell'anno raga bellissima
beh io posso sipro esiste il condom e
ragazzi chiamato un po meno allora
persona mettiamo nell'insalata e un
attimo allora no no no no nel forno nel
forno stai fermo che devi spiegare ciò
basta scopare
capiamoci un attimo basta fare bambini
allora no questo non si fa il tesoro
questo gioco costa esci dal forno porca
vacca morta dai beh cosa stai facendo
peggio fermi no no basta bambini basta
bambini pound devi stare fermo a questo
gioco consiste nel tenere di barbie kaz
6 spider man
devi tenere i bambini che questi ragazzi
che questa coppia giovane fa ed evitare
che si suicidino credito ai tre vite
quindi credo si possono suscitare al
massimo tre volte non lo so perché non
ho mai giocato spero di sì perché
probabilmente moriranno molto presto
questa famiglia è veramente meravigliosa
perché fa un sacco di bambini che vanno
in mente di farne tanti non si sta nel
freezer e povero deficiente che deve
tenerli a bada so io non credo di essere
in grado di poter avere mai figli nella
mia vita stai fermo cavalcano fatto
uscire la rabbia basta stare né fraser
aree che affermi che il sono 99 bambini
a tenere state non si guardano i video
di fa vj smettila dormio grazie a dio ha
quindi poi ci sono dei punti che è
successo un bambino è morto come teniamo
occupati bambini tu dormi
anche perché non puoi dormire è stato
almeno qualcuno no perché nel letto c'è
la peggio merda via dorme ok lo stesso
scaffale tu dove sei finito nel forno
fuori al four two stai dentro cesto tu
smettetela di fa di chiamare voi due
acquistare anche tu nella culla per
favore fuori dal forno nella culla nella
lavatrice ragazzi non usate il conto per
cortesia usate i condom che sono poi i
risultati sono incasinati vedete pietro
si può uscire qui no quella è morta
nella lavatrice pietro ammorbidente del
cestino nel cestino mettiti l'eccessiva
perfetto nel cestino ci stanno i bambini
tu nel secchio smettetela di scopa
arrivata 20 a perché il record sta nel
più bambini possibile cioè in base a
quanti bambini
il record degli battermi presso record
eventi a me tenerne uno a easy no il
favorito della muscia lance con cui
entra nel forno c'è un deficiente che le
porte sono chiuse è semplice perché vedo
tutto quindi è semplice de nerli però no
no mi potrei mai essere padre io non può
certi ma i bambini non dovrebbero
dormire 12 ore al giorno perché non
dormi qual è il tuo problema sei nato
stupido dormi mamma mia amica se mai
dovesse avere un filo scappo in messico
immediatamente ecco che nascono così può
mai una donna essere così fertile
possono passare almeno nove mesi da un
bambino all'altro in modo tale che non
abbia gente da mantenere mio dio che
guarda i video di mente bis cosa stanno
facendo questi sono in bilico su una su
della marmellata
come no guardare video rimette vi sia
stato scherzando vai dormire
state tutti no nel forte non me ne sono
accorto almeno fate una roba simpatica
guardate tutti quanti i miei video che
usiamo i nomi aumentate le pubblicità le
viuzze facci big money di qom proventi
computer tutti quanti ad aggiornare
video di favi genera cassa giornata i
video giornate che facciamo le vite
giusta equa ok tu stai qua to fermo to
fuori dalla lavatrice
c'è un altro posto dove li posso mettere
un armadio no nell'armadio e stai chiuso
di porca vacca 24 giada è tantissimo
un'altra porta sia aperta ormai di figli
mi chiedevo affittare 25 ore di sit per
giornate i miei video che devo pagare 25
baby sitter per quando sarò grande è
morto qualcuno e ma io godo soltanto
hard non so neanche chi è morto pensate
quanto non riesco a gestirli ve lo giuro
non sono anche dove se dovessi a morto
quel cristiano li stai lì dentro
no no chi è chi sa chi è fuori dal
freezer per cortesia o dimenticato
essere anche questa stanza totalmente si
sono suicidati lì però non li ho visti
vabbè 28 direi che possiamo provare con
l'ultimo tentativo 28 è veramente tanto
e cioè non credo di riuscire a batterlo
pro proviamoci non si sa mai l'ultimo
tentativo di oggi fa vige vi insegna
come fare all'amore l'amore si fa
tenendosi per mano
così non è vero che devi in fila le cose
non è vero che sono cagate son cagate lo
insegno io per ragazzino che sono
riuscire a gestire un bambino nella mia
vita figurati 28 quali problemi o ati
infilo io direttamente nel forum
magari non sono italiani non capì hughes
del condom use the condom don't stop che
basta infilarsi nel freezer
ma poi perché un bambino si deve
infilare nel freezer c'è questa il
contrario di come schiavo quel gioco che
giocato da stefano quello con dead diva
vedove il bambino si deve suicidare
vinci se ti suicidi e questo è contrario
non devi devi far suicidare i bambini va
beh
la daneco attori sono a metà a metà
rispetto a prima e già non ci sto più
facendo come ho fatto a far 28 prima è
impossibile chiudetevi nell'armadio
poi uno entra nel freezer altri lo
guardano dicono cos'è il freezer e
centrano pure loro maledizione smetti a
riguardare i video di non aprire la
porta non aprire la porta a non entrare
nel freezer non entrare nel forno non
entrare nel frazer vi ammazzo tutta la
famiglia di stermino io vi stermino
tutti quanti basta entrare al forno
perché vi siete accalcati tutti lei
frigia ma volete farmi incazzare che 22
ragazze ma 22 è incredibile spostati da
lì per cortesia fuori dal freezer chi è
successo dove entra all autrice tra
novacco 23 mag a impossibile come ho
fatto a far 28 prima impossibile d'armi
muro e questo porta hanno aperto quando
poi si possono uccidere nella vasca da
bagno ti panabaker poi nella porta nuova
che sia aperta non c'è neanche un posto
dove posso metterli per tenerli in
sicurezza questi solmaz guarda guarda
liana bayer ag a 28 siamo arrivati al
record di prima incredibile 29 raga 29
record madonna
dichiara che board che si è infilato
dentro qualcosa non cavalca smettetela
non ce la farò mai più diventando una
macchina da guerra ma che roba è ormai
vivono vivono dentro il freezer c'è dopo
essere guarda entrano ed entra uno di 3
secondi nel freezer madonna raga quanto
hanno scovato sti 2 dai l'ho tolto l'ho
tolto perché non era lui era dentro la
vasca da bagno ben 34 raga io poi sono
io dopo questo video ve lo giuro vado a
vedere la gente cosa ha fatto
eccolo basta scappare voi basta il
freezer
no è impossibile perso pezzi già fatta
l'ho tolto incredibile 35 aiuto che
aiutano lo trovo
ma ora è diventato impossibile ceranesi
troppe stanno entrando è ormai
ingestibile ormai ho perso solo
questioni secondi in questione di
secondi raga 39 ceva come ho fatto a
fare 39 lo sono anch'io 39 ragazze non
so se vi rendete conto quanto sogni in
tanto sognato un fenomeno progaming
progaming vali valic e sport in crea
altro che overwatch altro che thomas che
gioca overwatch questi suoi giochi
questo il mio nome knicks lo sto
sfruttando benissimo che il computer
della madonna e ti fa girare player a
non batte il gran in 4k
per questo lo sto usando faccio solo
bene sono io figlio sì che so come si
gioca
metti a riguardo ai video no no non è
morto molto parte non è morto sono fatta
senatrice ragazzi 42 basta babbo mi
chiamo i due veramente li ammazzerei
basta per court basta non ne voglio più
sapere
ho fatto 42 c'è il credibile ragazzo non
soddisfatto anche sarà un gioco delle
palle almeno su riuscito a fare un
record incredibile va bene così però che
mi sia piaciuto ragazzi in classe si è
riuscito per quanto mi piace ricordatevi
di usare il condom
se vi piace e noi dove minchia filtro
telecomando sono presi i bambini sti
maledetti deficienti dai ragazzi
[Musica]